[Music]
can we talk a bit more about what what's
happening at the moment in relation to
North Korea which is something we
haven't mentioned yet so some people are
saying okay a few months ago three or
four months ago we were worried about a
nuclear war in North Korea now we've got
Kim jong-un meeting with the president
of South Korea deciding to a bid to host
the Olympics together agreeing to
denuclearization and that that is down
to Donald Trump's tough foreign policy
no way I mean I think his foreign policy
has worked incredibly well on one
country in the world and that's China I
was in China a few weeks ago and was
very struck but they see Donald Trump in
completely different terms to how he's
seen in the West most of my American
friends and all of my European friends
see Trump as you described it at the
beginning as a kind of buffoon who's
self-defeating and kind of destructive
and doing all sorts of things which
which undermine American interests and I
do a kind of fundamental level as I said
in my first answer but at the same time
in China they think that he he's both
their kind of master strategist and a
master tactician but he basically pushed
they think that he's been declaring war
on them on kind of three fronts on an
economic front on the kind of political
front and an ideological front and they
use North Korea as the kind of prime
example where he ups the ante creates a
real sense of crisis puts the Chinese
government under so much pressure to
introduce sanctions that they shift
their position six or seven times he
they get to the point where the North
Koreans almost see the South Koreans has
kind of sworn enemies their closest
allies with the only country that they
have a treaty relationship with and then
when he realized to say he's run out of
Road he shifts tack basically tries to
do a deal and and then opens up a new
front with the Chinese on trade which
we're now on at the moment and I think
actually you know having seen various
different presidents and lots of
Europeans fail to make any headway on
the Chinese there is some kind of logic
in terms of how he's handling with China
is he helping on North Korea um I think
it's much too early to tell I'm happy
that they're talking rather than him
threatening to you know tweeting about
rocket man and threatening pre-emptive
nuclear strikes at the moment but I do
worry that as a result of mistakes in in
Western foreign policy over the last few
decades we created very perverse
incentives for the for the North Koreans
having seen what happened to Saddam
Hussein to Gadhafi I think it's quite
difficult to see why North Korea
wouldn't want to have nuclear weapons
and why North Korean leader wouldn't
want to have any clear Hawaii trust
Western assurances that we will not try
and change the regime if if they get rid
of their nuclear weapon so I'd be amazed
if they really do do that and then it
ripping up the Iran nuclear deal exactly
the moment that you're trying to do a
deal with the North Koreans on nuclear
weapons seems like a inexplicable and
sort of catastrophic decision so we'll
see what happens I also worry that if
this fails is it's quite likely - it
will then empower the Hawks like John
Bolton within the administration who
want to go back to using military
solutions against North Korea and I
think that is the the scariest thing so
I do think we have every incentive to
try and make this work as much as
possible I think that you have very wide
leadership being shown by the South
Korean authorities that have been trying
to handle and to manage Trump but
they're in a very risky position because
they exposed themselves enormously and
Trump is totally unreliable and
unpredictable and that could be another
big casualty of this affair but I think
you know the time to make pass judgment
on his on his North Korean diplomacy is
probably in sort of five or six years
time rather than at the moment yeah okay
so George we've heard a very passionate
enunciation from you of the rules-based
international order can you tell us what
you think should replace it and and
don't shout please because you've really
got a mic mic on and I think it's just
too loud for everybody currently let me
decide
the tone of voice in which I well that's
my ears we don't want another half-life
of a conflict between you and I the
Donald Trump is an unpredictable
unstable person it's not strong and
stable genius he's a bull in a china
shop and to mix the metaphor even a stop
clock is Right twice a day and he was
right to meet with the North Korean
leadership and he was right to encourage
a rapprochement between North and South
Korea and it's going swimmingly
in fact it's practically a love-in the
Koreans are embracing each other with a
warmth and vigor that no one could
possibly have imagined and Donald
Trump's predecessors would never have
permitted this is important Barack Obama
would never have met Kim jong-un and
therefore the permafrost of North South
Korea relations would have continued so
and not only would Barack Obama not have
done it Hillary Clinton would not have
done it and so if we are looking
objectively at this thing you have to
see that Trump was right about Korea and
the others were wrong because Korea has
been for decades a clear and present
danger to world peace and and stability
it's not I'm passionately denouncing the
rules-based international order
I am passionately denouncing the fact
that there is no rules-based
international order you just called
lawlessness a rules-based international
order with some mistakes some breaches
but how many breaches does it take to
invalidate your thesis in the first
place if you have what you call an
international rules
a system in the world which is not just
reached not just mistakes
but which kills millions of people and
renders the whole world completely
unstable how many times does that need
to happen before your thesis is
invalidated now for most people it long
ago ceased to be credible to call it a
rules-based international order and I
refuse to accept your thesis that's all
I haven't got a thesis I'm just asking
you to what you think well you think
this is that there is an international
rules based all I see and and and my
case is that it's abundantly clear that
there has not been and that therefore
attempts to exceptional eyes Trump which
is the liberal mantra and nonsense he's
only been in 23 months four more debates
talks and interviews subscribe today to
the Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI
TV
you